alors ouais oui et non au nom d'act ok
ça match aller est tout à leur gré by
the nokia 33-10 c'était mon téléphone
préféré au début des années 2000 il en
existait toutes les couleurs des glières
bande grise des bleu à bandes grises des
bleus double et même des multicolores il
y en avait pour tous les goûts
si on se remet dans le contexte de
l'époque au début des années 2000 ça
c'était la référence
avant il y avait le 32 10 mais 33 disent
ah vraiment apporter quelque chose
faut dire qu'ils avaient pas de
smartphone à l'époque tout ce qui était
un acte il n'existait pas on en rêvait
tous mais ça n'existait pas pas de
smartphone samsung n'était absolument
pas positionnés sur le téléphonie mobile
il y avait une motorola qui régnait en
maître
nokia ne souvient pas si sony était déjà
positionné toujours est il que le nokia
33-10 a vraiment été le téléphone qui a
marqué toute une génération il était
pratique super robuste tu pouvais
l'éclaté ils se cassent et jamais c'est
pas comme les iphone qui ont des petites
rayures aujourd'hui où les samsung dès
que tu les fais à peine de tomber ça
pouvait se casser la gueule un paquet de
fois ça ne bougeait jamais et surtout le
33-10 avait un atout c'était son jeu le
snake le snec c'était un petit serpent
qui se déplaçait à la verticale et à
l'horizontale lui manger de choses plus
gros si c est à la fin ils risquaient de
se bouffer la cueillette avait perdu et
qui passait des heures à jouer à ce truc
c'était hyper addictif pour que c'était
probablement le premier jeu sur
téléphone qui a eu un succès de dingue
quelques années après puis après
l'arrivée des smartphones on connaît
tous nokia a décidé cette année en 2010
est de relancer son produit phare le
nokia 33 10
nouvelle génération remanier un plus
grand écran en couleur et qui rentrent
dans la catégorie ce qu'on appelle lé
dann fon les téléphones idiot on utilise
ce nom pour faire un petit peu si tu
veux le parallèle par rapport aux
smartphones les smartphones sont les
téléphones intelligents là on est sûr de
téléphonie de parce qu'en réalité il
fait pas grand chose tu peux téléphoner
tu vas avoir un réveil tu vas bord des
sms un appareil photo en 2 mégapixels
autant dire que c'est vraiment pour
faire quelques souvenirs mais tu pourras
pas à les développer la qualité sera
vraiment pourri et tu retrouves ce
fameux snake qui est en couleur était
cette fois ci peut faire différents
mouvements à l'heure des monnaies voilà
bon bref
alors tu peux demander pourquoi est ce
que nokia se positionnent sur ce 33 10
alors qu'aujourd'hui le marché a
tellement évolué que son truc ça vaut
plus rien et ben en finale c'est pas si
con que ça parce que le 33-10 nouvelle
génération va se positionner sur une
niche une toute petite niche la niche
des gens qui ne veulent pas être tout le
temps connecté qui ne veulent pas de
smartphone il va savoir qu'un a de plus
en plus et il faut un coup marketing au
final qui est extra parce que il joue
vraiment sur un côté vintage et sur le
succès du 33 10 je pense qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde connaît le no 4 en 3 10 la
catapulte sur youtube tu verras il ya
des vidéos sur le 33 10 des vidéos
d'ailleurs qu'il n'ya pas sur d'autres
téléphones qui à l'époque était aussi
référence de 33,10 a vraiment marqué sa
génération il ya vraiment cartonné donc
ils veulent effectivement déjà faire le
buzz dans les médias
et ça marche parce que regarde moi je
fais cette vidéo il ya plein d'autres
qui ont fait vidéos et tout le monde en
ce moment parle un petit peu du nokia 33
10 alors que fondamentalement il apporte
rien de bien neuf
seulement voilà il a un côté vintage on
en parle c'est le rétro c'est sympa ça
s'adresse vraiment à cette population
qui veut vraiment se déconnecter donc
ils ont vraiment un marché à prendre là
dessus surtout que nokia sur le marché
des smartphones c'est pas terrible
terrible donc là ils vont se positionner
là dessus
et à mon avis ils ont bien fait et ils
vont vraiment cartonné bon après au
niveau tarif c'est pas extraordinaire
le nouveau nokia 33 10 quand même coûté
la petite bagatelle de 49 euros alors tu
me diras 49 euros et quand même de
l'argent surtout qu'à ce prix là tu peux
toucher des smartphones ancienne
génération
ou alors vraiment des premiers prix avec
des abonnements bon donc tu dit celui-là
on téléphone nu au final pas non plus
des cônes en déconnant
enfin pas celui-là le nouveau no 43 10
après avec ce nouveau nokia il faut pas
s'attendre non plus à des miracles à un
navigateur internet si tu veux quand
même allé consulter une page donc la 4g
déjà il faut oublier la 3è normalement
il faut l'oublier et tu pourras te
connecter en 2g à travers le navigateur
opera mini donc tu iras pas bien loin
d'autant plus que l'épave aujourd'hui
même les pages mobiles sont plus en plus
gourmandes les images sont plus lourdes
parce que fatalement comme on est en 3g
voire en 4g tout va beaucoup plus vite
donc on peut mettre des pages un peu
plus lourd des images de meilleure
qualité un peu plus lourde donc en 2g
sur un opéra mini ça ne va pas aller
bien vite mais bon on pourra quand même
s'en fait sur quelques sites mais c'est
hyper malin parce que il faut quand même
savoir que ce téléphone là le 33 10
anciennes générations a été quand même
vendu à plus de 126 millions
d'exemplaires à travers le monde c'était
vraiment un carton colossal de quoi
assurer le succès à nokia pour son tout
nouveau téléphone du moins être sûr que
tout le monde en a entendu parler ils se
vendent ou qui se vendent pas ça on sait
absolument pas si ce téléphone va
marcher mais en tout cas c'est une
excellente idée
une bonne nouvelle pour tous ceux qui
veulent un téléphone idiot pas forcément
trop cher et ce nouveau nokia il n'a
qu'a eu pas mal d'avantagés la lavande a
déjà d'être léger 133 g avec un écran un
peu plus grand et légèrement arrondi il
existe de plusieurs couleurs
pis ce nouveau téléphone si vraiment tu
faire des économies c'est pas mal tu
peux faire 22 heures d'appels sans
recharger la batterie
tu peux le garder un mois en mode veille
tu peux mettre deux cartes sim
si jamais tu as un abonnement pro et un
abonnement particulier un appareil photo
je te disais 2 millions de pixels avec
un petit flash led pour pouvoir quand
même équilibré et pouvoir bien voir ce
que tu prends en photo un clavier t9
pour ceux qui n'ont pas connu le t9
c'était vraiment truc tout con pour
écrire antennes 9 tu appuyer plusieurs
fois pour avoir le à une fois le des
deux fois le ces trois fois et tu
écrivais tout comme ça le t9 à la fin on
s'habitue et sauf qu'aujourd'hui avec le
tactile directement sur les smartphones
c'est beaucoup plus pratique quand un
lecteur mp3 avec le pouvoir troquer
talmudique jusqu'à 32 gigas grâce à une
carte microsd club pourra mettre
directement dans ton téléphone
et puis tu peux aussi écouter la radio
si ça te fait plaisir si tu en as envie
donc le nouveau nokia 33-10 il s'adresse
vraiment une petite cible aux gens qui
aiment le vin
ce qui était amoureux de ce téléphone là
qui ne veulent pas s'emmerder qui
veulent de la simplicité qui veulent du
pas cher c'est un téléphone qui n'a pas
se vendre par millions millions millions
mais en tout cas a toutes ses chances de
se démarquer par rapport à toutes ces
générations de dôme found téléphone
idiot je sais pas quel téléphone toi tu
as si tu envisages de déconnecter site
en a un peu marre d'être tout le temps
connecté sur ton téléphone à surfer
regarder youtube avait un peu une chose
plein de choses différentes
dis moi ce que tu penses de ce style de
téléphone alors respectez suffisamment
vieux pour avoir connu le nokia 33 10
est ce que tu en a eu 1 1 est ce que tu
as joué pendant des heures au snake et
est-ce que tu envisagerait d'acheter ce
télélphone l'art le nouveau nokia 33-10
pour 49 euros dis moi ce que t'en penses
tu me mets tout en commentaire en
dessous
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'hésite pas regarder celle là aussi
abonne toi mais maintenant commentaires
je te dire très bientôt et puis je te
laisse avec le nokia